a plan you gonna have a super bowl party  yes no super bowl party no super bowl  party if you're true football fan you do  not go to uh super bowl parties because  it's all a bunch of losers who don't  watch it all year and what they do is  they talk during the game  and then they shut up during the  commercial and then the game comes back  they're like oh how do you think that  one caught huh  that's it funny i thought that one stunk  and it's just like  i just the rage that goes through me  through the game and i just you know  ended up fighting you know with somebody  so  what i do is i i tape the game i let it  go like 90 minutes  90 minutes i shut off everything and  then i start watching that way i can  fast forward through all of the crap  all of the fireworks the bands you don't  like you don't like the halftime show no  no i really sound like a grumpy old man  but i i just want to watch the game  right  i'm just going to be me sitting alone  screaming at my tv